hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2011 american superhero action movie
called the green hornet
the movie begins with a young rich boy
named brit whose father james reid is
the owner of the daily sentinel
turns out that brit was sent home by his
teachers after a schoolyard fight he
admits that he tries to defend himself
from the bullies but the father does not
believe him and gets angry
he takes his most favorite superhero
figure and pulls out its head
20 years later benjamin chudnovsky the
mafia boss who is la under his command
comes to a bar to give a warning to its
owner danny clear because he opened the
bar without his permission and payment
however the bar owner disrespects him
and deliberately mispronounces his name
into tchaikovsky
he then states that chadnovsky is
old-fashioned and is not scary anymore
since benjamin is a psychopath who
always wants to be feared by everyone he
feels insulted with that statement he
immediately pulls out his gun and starts
shooting at his bodyguards killing them
on the spot
he points his two-barreled gun at
danny's head while asking him whether he
is scary or not
left with no choice danny admits that
benjamin is scary but he suggests he
changes his name to a scarier name
benjamin accepts the suggestion and
calmly walks out of the building just
after danny thinks that he's safe he
finds a briefcase which is actually a
bomb and the mafia boss subsequently
blows up the whole bar
meanwhile brit who is now a grown-up man
is jobless and spends his whole day
partying with girls
he lives in his dad's luxurious mansion
and every morning he has always served a
good cup of coffee
not long after james appears and
expresses his disappointment towards his
one and only son who has been
humiliating him through his
inappropriate behavior
one day while having fun with girls brit
receives devastating news
the media reports that his father james
has been found dead from an allergic
reaction to a bee sting to honor his
dedication as an honest and kind person
james friends and colleagues built him a
statue after the funeral brit who is
lost and is not ready for the big
responsibility fires most of his
father's staff
the next morning brit is disappointed
when his morning coffee doesn't taste as
good as usual
he complains to the only remaining maid
and orders her to call the barista back
cato the barista who also used to be
james carr mechanic returns to the
mansion and shows brit the machine he
always uses to make the coffee
brit is amazed when he sees the very
advanced coffee machine and cato admits
that he built the machine
single-handedly because of cato's
amazing skill brit becomes eager to get
to know more about him cato tells brit
that he's born in shanghai and lived in
an orphanage since he was four
he then ran away and lived on the street
while working as a mechanic until james
came to his garage to fix his car
james was happy with his work at that
time and decided to recruit him after
that cato takes brit to james garage
where he shows him james bulletproof car
which of course was also built by cato
they subsequently go to cato's personal
workshop where he reveals to brita's
drawings and skill to open beer bottles
with bare hands
they get drunk and brit tells cato about
how much he hates his father for ripping
off his favorite toy's head
still that night they go to the
graveyard and brit decides to cut off
the statue's head for revenge
as he walks back to the car brit
accidentally sees a couple getting
mugged by gangsters
he attempts to save them but gets beaten
up until cato appears and fights them
while fighting it turns out that kato
possesses a unique ability that allows
him to see things in a slow mode when
his heart starts pumping fast after
eliminating all the gangsters they drive
away but later realize that they're
being chased by the police who think
that they're criminals
because they keep refusing to pull over
the officer shoots them but deals no
effect to the side window
cato eventually activates the car's
secret weapon which allows them to
entirely escape from the cop in the
mansion they celebrate their success and
brit suggests they team up to fight
crime in the city cato initially
hesitates with the idea as the news
reports them as the bad guy but brit
manages to convince him telling him to
utilize his talents for the greater good
despite the fact that they will be
targeted by both the cops and criminals
the next day they come to his company hq
and brit orders the manager to make his
statue head-cutting action as the
headline on the newspaper so that people
will think that he is dangerous since
the staff have no idea that brit is the
culprit they decide to call the man as
the green hornet which is inspired from
the bee that killed james
the green hornet becomes viral and this
news affects the reputation of d.a
scanlon as the media thinks that the
city is not safe anymore on the other
hand benjamin also learns about the
green hornet and is offended by the fact
that someone is scarier than him
back at the office cato meets lenore who
is the temp for brit's secretarial
position
brit interviews her and immediately
decides to hire her as his permanent
secretary after knowing that she
understands criminology
in the evening cato develops a more
advanced car for them while brit
determines which costume they should
wear
the mechanic equips the car with roodles
some modern weapons and last but not
least ejector seats
several weeks have passed and brit is
amazed by the fact that cato manages to
transform an old car into an imperial
car
while testing their brand new car brick
calls lenore asking her to send the
crime maps that'll be used to determine
the best location for their debut as the
green hornet as they arrive at the most
dangerous place in the city they
confront the local gangsters and
challenge them
cato does a 360 spin hitting the
gangsters with the car before they get
out and start knocking them out one by
one brit then interrogates one of the
thugs who reveals that they work for
benjamin
they even break into benjamin's meth lab
where brit tells the worker to give the
green hornet card to his boss
the next day the guy gives the card to
benjamin and claims that they're scarier
than him which makes the boss feel
insulted and then shoots him to death
meanwhile brit urges his employees to
promote the green hornet with provoking
lines
since then brit and cato keep
eliminating the criminals while causing
chaos in the city making the cops d.a
scanlon and benjamin are after them at
the same time
realizing that brit doesn't have much
fighting experience cato gives him a gas
gun but he thinks that it's insulting he
then accidentally shoots the gas gun in
his face which makes him unconscious for
11 days
as brit awakens he's surprised when
finding out that cato has built two
backup cars and has fixed the gas
shortening its effect to only last for
one hour
he then shoots kato with a gas gun
back to benjamin his men inform him that
his subordinates think that their boss
is not that powerful anymore and most of
them decide to be independent to regain
his popularity benjamin plans to kill
the green hornet he subsequently sends
kato and brit an email asking them to
meet up to discuss a business
opportunity cato thinks that it's a trap
but brit becomes too selfish and insists
with his plan
the following day they rendezvous with
benjamin as planned but they later
realize that they have fallen into
benjamin's trap
he attempts to bury them alive along
with a car
cato launches the missiles which
eventually prevent them from being
buried alive while also killing one of
benjamin's friends chile
they then managed to escape from the
site and take a taxi home
upon returning to the mansion cato is
unhappy with benjamin's behavior and
they both start arguing brick claims
that he's the real hero and cato is just
his sidekick not partner
on the contrary cato tells him that he's
nothing without him they later fight
until brit finds out that cato can't
swim and decides to throw him afloat
then leaves him alone
after that he angrily fires both cato
and lenore
on the other hand benjamin is very
devastated after losing one of his
comrades and is willing to give one
million dollars to anyone who can bring
the green hornet to him dead or alive
the words are spread among the criminals
in the city causing a lot of innocent
people who wear green clothes to be
ruthlessly killed the manager shows brit
the consequence of putting the green
horn in his headline and politely asks
him to stay out his way in managing the
company
left with no option brit meets up with
d.a scanlon to get some help
instead he finds out that scanlon is
corrupt after the da attempts to bribe
him to slant the news for his
re-election which is rejected by brit
meanwhile benjamin is planning to change
his name from chadnovsky into
bloodnowski hoping that will increase
his charisma but it seems like his
friend is against that idea
thus benjamin shoots him and announces
his new name to the others
back to brit he comes to lenoir and asks
him to work for him again
shortly after scanlan invites brit for
dinner to renegotiate to which he agrees
meanwhile cato accidentally finds out
that the dinner is a trap and
immediately drives over to the
restaurant at the restaurant scanlon
reveals to brit that he and benjamin are
allies and they both have a mutualistic
relationship
he also adds that he was the one who
murdered his father by injecting
apotoxin which is commonly found in a
bee sting after he refused to corporate
unbeknownst to scanlon brit has recorded
all their conversations from the
beginning
not long after cato comes to the rescue
and the gunfight ensues thanks to the
missile from the car they both managed
to escape from the restaurant and drive
away at the same time benjamin picks
scanlon up and they start chasing after
them
after a long chase and dozens of bullets
being fired brit and cato managed to
destroy several benjamin's men's cars
and eventually managed to break into the
daily sentinel's hq where brit intends
to upload the conversations onto the
internet however the car is stuck in the
printing machine forcing brit to run to
his office by foot
benjamin who is now wearing a red suit
and gas mask attempts to shoot brit but
he escapes by jumping to the ground
floor benjamin and his men continue
chasing him until he's cornered
luckily the car breaks free from the
printing machine and cato immediately
picks him up
they then crash into an elevator and
somehow manage to ascend to the highest
level of the building
since the car was built with a
front-wheel drive system they still can
drive the car until they arrive at
britt's office only to find out that the
conversation was not recorded as he
forgot to press the play button
at the same time cato tries to buy some
time by fighting benjamin and his men
himself but unfortunately he gets his
leg pinned underneath a table when
benjamin is about to kill kato brit
somehow suddenly possesses the same time
freezing ability as cato and starts
eliminating everyone this action
distracts benjamin for a second and cato
uses this opportunity to break free and
subsequently impales the mafia boss in
the eyes a swat team shows up and fires
at the green hornet hitting brit in the
shoulder they get into their
half-destroyed car hit scanlon with it
and drive off the building while they
escape through the ejector seats the two
flee to lenoir's place where they have
to reveal their identity to her so that
she wants to help them the next day brit
announces to the public that he wants to
rebuild the new sentinel and promotes
the manager as the new chief editor
in an attempt to convince the public
that he's not the green hornet he plans
a scenario with cato where he pretends
to get shot by the green hornet while
also allowing him to be taken to the
hospital
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching